we are very happy to have in our studio
Klaus he art Frederickson administer of
an employment of Denmark mr. Fredricksen
has been a senior official in the ruling
Labour Party Liberal Party since 1971
and from 1985 to 2001 he was the
secretary-general of the Liberal Party
and since 2001 he has been the minister
of employment and mr. Frederick sins
record in the ministry is something for
env two most European capitals because
under his leadership Denmark has
achieved the highest employment rate in
Europe unemployment rate is now four
point five percent which is the kind of
30-year low compared to 1990s when
Denmark heard about twelve percent
unemployment so this is a very enable
achievement on top of that mr.
Fredricksen and Prime Minister and
Deputy Prime Minister they have formed a
globalization Council which has been non
factum of the first in Europe to address
the question of globalization head on
and come up with some very concrete
physicians so we're very happy to have
mr. prediction in our studio welcome to
Yale mr. Ericsson thank you very much so
my first question to you would be how
did he do it this lowering the
unemployment rate to four point five
percent is a quite remarkable in Europe
where unemployment it is so much higher
sompting twelve percent some places in
the short term we looked at figures in
the 2002 2003 and everybody was
expecting things to change in Europe you
know it the German economy was doing
poorly the French economy was doing
poorly but the economy's told us all the
time that
the upswing was just around the corner
so we should just have some patience but
at a certain time in 2003 2004 we
decided that we would create our own
economic upswing and we started a
consumer-driven drive in the economy we
made some tax reductions some public
investments and people had more money on
their hands and from that time on the
Danish economy has performed very well
and I think is you shouldn't break but I
think it's the best the most solid
economy that you have in all Europe we
pay off our debts we have surpluses on
the Palin balance payment and as you
said we have very low unemployment now
Denmark is now very well known for this
model of flex security combining
flexibility for the employers to hire
and fire workers and job security for
the workers at the same time now this is
in apparently kind of pretty conflicted
task so how did you go about addressing
this two different goals in one package
in a way it is a paradox that you have a
country with the highest or second
highest tax burden in the world the cost
of living is very high and you have very
high allowances if you lose your job or
you get sick you get practically the
same amount as if you were working and
then we have so low and
unemployment and I often say that if we
had discussed this fifteen years ago my
answer would have been that we should
reduce the allowances we should reduce
the subsidies for four people and we
should reduce the taxes but it shows
that the combination of having high
allowances and a very easy hire and fire
system you can hire people you can fire
people very easily that combination
makes people braver i think in changing
jobs in willingness to try something
else because i understand that once the
worker is fired he or she normally gets
a job back within a night within a year
normally seventy percent of them yes get
a job within that period of time they
and then we have the third leg of our
policies is that we have an active labor
market policy where if people have been
unemployed for some months not finding
an adequate job within their field of
profession then we start with upgrading
their qualifications and Retraining the
retraining appearance so we have a very
active retraining we have high
allowances so they don't have to leave
house and home when they lose their job
and then for the employer the very
important thing that if he get your
orders and needs more staff he can hire
them immediately if he loses orders he
can fire people and that gives us a very
very high flexibility i can give you a
number if you should normally be careful
with numbers but the danish workforce is
2.5 million people and each year 800,000
people change jobs and that means that
there is sorry
lying strong movement in in the labor
force and and their social security
medical benefit this they're all the
time that yes we have a you have get
ninety percent of your income for a four
year period when you get unemployed
quite a long period but it stresses they
need for us to see to that people apply
for jobs because then that is of course
the weakness in our system when you have
high allowances that are comparable to
your original color are the earnings
then the system has to be very
consequent and very strict that if you
do not seek jobs if you do not take
adequate jobs then of course you are
sanctioned by not getting your
allowances as the allowance is reduced
or disappear for a period of time I
think so that's the kind of bit of stick
yes to make sure that people yes do seek
job and don't stay on the door yes right
now this of course this high insurance
that you are paying the workers it costs
the government a lot of money and you
are raising high tax to pay for that so
does that cause any discontent among
people that they are paying such high
tax funnily enough all the surveys you
see these days people are not asking for
lower taxes they are asking for a higher
quality in the public services so there
is no there is no pressure for lower
taxes but of course Denmark faces a
long-term challenge in globalization
with lower production costs lower
taxation elsewhere in the world so
eventually we have gradually to change
our tax system and lower our texts we we
realize that
so the your corporate tax how does it
compare to other European countries it
is about the same about the Senate yes
but compared to the developing countries
it is pretty high yes that's what it is
two years ago two years ago we we
realized that we had some challenges in
in the Danish society we have first of
all demographic challenge the people get
older and older and live and are
healthier and healthier and the
generations to take over are much
smaller I can give you a figure that the
1947 generation is the biggest
generation in our country it had some
ninety-four ninety-five thousand
newborns the 1986 generation which is
now about to take over is only fifty two
thousand so this puts a challenge on on
our society that was then we set up a
welfare Commission ask some independent
economists to describe the challenges
that the Danish society would face in
the coming 10 20 30 40 years they came
up with their proposals in January this
year and they were looking at how can we
increase the workforce in Denmark and
they pointed at three things if we could
get the young people faster through the
educational system so they could come
out a half a year or a year earlier that
would give a contribution to the
workforce if we could
have much higher participation by
immigrants from third-world countries
the unemployment among them is
unfortunately much higher than by the
Danes but could we reduce it to the same
level as the veins it would give a very
good very good contribution for the
future future workforce and then thirdly
if we could persuade the older people to
stay one or two years longer on the
labour market what is the retirement age
and it is 65 and then we have some early
retirement schemes where you can
withdraw at 60 then we made a compromise
in the danish parliament with 158
members out of the 179 members of
parliament where we postponed over the
next 20 years the retirement age from 65
to 67 and on the early retirement scheme
from 62 to 60 from 60 to 62 and that
gives us sufficient power to take this
thing out of the demographic problem
that we have then we set up a tripod
Commission the government the employees
and the employers to see if we could
establish what we have been talking
about for many years how can you
establish a system of lifelong learning
where you save money for education at a
later stage in your life because maybe
your line of business is threatened by
globalization it's moved to China or
India and then you have to do something
else and we made an agreement with the
partners the social partners that at the
first coming tariffs negotiations they
will try to make this a part of the
tariff so the percentage is paid into a
personal account for each employee in
Denmark and in 20 years time or so there
will be sufficient money that you can
have your concern your your pay
compensation through these funds and
then the state guarantees that education
is always available yeah in your the
globalization strategy that you launched
in this August yeah the three components
one is education and stepping up
education and giving people higher
education right now forty five percent
only go for secondary in university
education you want to step that up and
in this this three-pronged strategy that
you have if you could explain little bit
as to what you know intense the whole
exercise was to get more people on the
labor markets in the next 10 20 30 years
and we made that primarily by postponing
the retirement age and also we're
postponing the age for the early
retirement scheme we then established a
lifelong learning system which is
because people are challenged by the
globalization and more and more of us I
think may realize that we have to change
land line of business within our life if
you are trained in one profession you do
not as you had before the guarantee that
you will be pensioned in that trade so
that is why we concentrate on lifelong
learning and then the Prime Minister
himself set up globalization council
where there were
the CEOs there were union leaders there
were heads of universities and other
institutions they were not representing
these institutions but they were their
own capacity but of course it was 25
veins with influence in the Danish
society and they discussed globalization
what are the challenges we meet and they
came up with I think 335 recommendations
within the field of education research
innovation and things like that because
we realize we have to to strengthen the
educational system we have seen the pisa
I don't really know if you are familiar
with the pisa examinations where the
european school system as such is tested
so you can see which country has the
best school system and we unfortunately
could see that in math and in science we
were in in the middle and that was in
our opinion not good enough to be in the
middle of these countries so we decided
to spend billions billions that we save
from postponing the retirement age and
the early retirement schemes we use this
money for science research and
innovation yeah four percent gdp for the
L&D that's your target I in this
globalization strategy that I read I did
see much reference to immigration what
what is your policy in terms of
encouraging immigration we
have first of all the task of getting
the immigrants that we haven't been
marked today out on the labor market I'm
sorry to say that we have not been
successful enough in integrating
immigrants in the labor market we had
for many years had wrong philosophy we
thought that when people came to Denmark
it was important that they learned the
language that they learned about the
Danish society that they were prepared
for coming out in the Danish society but
as everybody realizes integrations
integration goes through a job and as we
kept these immigrants away from a job
too long I know when you know that the
one of the big problems in our societies
are that the longer you are away from a
job the more difficult it is to get back
to a job and by having that policy for
many years that they should learn danish
first we failed on this issue we've now
changed things and and we are now doing
everything we can to get people a job as
fast as possible after they arrived in
the country and and Android we have been
confirmed in that since we've been here
and seen how you do that and people
manage much better than they do in the
integrative much better yes in our
system so we will work on several fronts
will have a very pragmatic task nowt to
take the immigrants we have so to say by
the hand and take them to the companies
because the problem is the companies do
not seek the immigrants and the
immigrants do not seek the companies so
we have a very low practical tasks
to do to connect the two parties and
then we have significant the programs
that subsidizes their salaries when they
come out to the employer and we can buy
colleagues off for hours during the week
to function as mentors for them helping
them in on the job that is one very very
important task that we have and we have
some success with it and as we started
out this conversation we have a very low
unemployment and that of course helps us
immensely solving this problem but the
general unemployment rate is four point
five percent but what is unemployment
rate among the immigrants from third
world countries as the OCD definition
goes is fifty percent fifty percent so
that that is actually a major problem is
and and if we can reduce that percent
true to the four point five or even ten
percent this will be an immense country
contribution to solving our long-term
problems but then of course we have
green card arrangements and the Europe
was the eight new members came in Europe
in 2002 and of course we employ many
poles Lithuanians Latvians that can come
yeah I don't ask you because since the
EU often immigration policies are
adapted what has been impact on Denmark
in terms of a level up from Eastern
Europe is that it's been very moderate
you know every time Europe is enlarged
there are these big scare campaigns that
we will be also run
by people but it doesn't happen and it's
been a very organized way but it has
cept us immensely in construction for
example in agriculture where we have a
big need of main power and people from
Poland Lithuania and so on are helping
us tremendously out of that yeah even
even I understand even the postal
service I'm not able to get enough
postal delivery person that's right
there is a contradiction that to deliver
post and to deliver newspapers we have
to import volatile from poles hope from
Poland to perform their job yeah now the
this latest recent arrest of Danish
Muslims from audience is that a
confirmation that your diagnosis was
correct or is it a challenge that you
have to encounter I think our diagnosis
diagnosis is correct that you have to
integrate through jobs and if especially
young people walk around unemployed of
course they develop a dissatisfaction
feeling of inferiority or forgetting
this part by the society and even though
I think that most immigrants find
themselves at home in Denmark of course
when when you kind of solve these
problems and do not get these young
people jobs it creates a frustration
that will unfortunately sometimes break
out in in very unpleasant things the
question though is this that this
evident alienation of Sam yield who
being Dennis themselves who want to
actually
last a bomb in Denmark is something of a
shock I'm sure to the population now the
question is are they unhappy because
they are unemployed or they feel
infinite in the society or is it because
they are unhappy with the Danish foreign
policy of taking part in Iraq and
Afghanistan I think it's a mixture of
many things i think if for the most
young muslims in denmark they like
denmark that's what we're here they feel
that they are treated well and treated
the equal but of course in all societies
there are people who listen to
extremists and you'll find pockets
somewhere aware this is something that
could occur and we have in Denmark been
haven't had these experiences for many
years but of course since the cartoon
crisis in yes last winter the
consciousness of these problems have
become much clearer to us and that is
why we put an extra effort to get the
young people in the educational system
and get them get them jobs because we we
must realize that too many of them drop
out of the school system end up with too
bad qualifications in in danish and this
is where we have to start so now we have
made new apprentices 444 jobs with a
more practical entrance to an education
if you and then might want to be a
carpenter or a plumber you are after
school being placed at the school bench
starting with the theoretical things but
for this group that had some failures in
their school career they are not very
keen to be put on a school bench one
more time so we have to find other
entrances and and I think with some
success we do that they can come out
using their hands in practical work at
the beginning this carton controversy of
course cost danish business quite a
mountain middle east how is it doing is
it things back to normal or is still
what we hear is that it is back to
normal fully back to normal yeah and
there are no repercussions our love our
la was one of the most yes hardest
hitters our lives back alleys back yes
and so what listen would you have did
you draw from this cartoon controversy
how can it be avoided in this kind of
situation I think there will be a
general awareness of it because I have
to make a personal confession in that
field filled out I was never aware that
it was forbidden to make a picture of
the prophet and we are so used to
cartoons I see myself everyday kind of
cartoon in newspapers so frankly I
didn't react when it came up but are the
one hand we shall respect people's
religious feelings but on the other hand
I think it's very important to stress
that when you live in a democratic
country you play by the Democratic rules
and we have to be very firm on
very firm on on on the right for each
individual within the frame of framework
of legislation to express his or hers
opinion and we cannot accept that there
are some things that cannot be said so
both parties have to learn from each
other we do not wish to offend people's
feelings but on the other hand when you
live in a democratic state you must
fully understand the conditions of such
a state denmark has been on the rare
european countries which strongly
supported the US intervention in Iraq
and is actually still now about 500
troops troops there how has been the
public reaction to this Danish
involvement in Iraq it has been
supported all the way we were of course
when we the request came from the United
States in the beginning there was an i
think in any ma city that we should
participate in the war but since the
decision was made there has been in all
polls